happy sabbath and welcome everyone to question and
answer with elder randy skeet on the word inspired
i'm your host denisha mccurchion and today we
are joined with special guests elder randy skeet
brother jonathan david archie brother kevin
gomez and sister stacy ann brown today
we are discussing probation and will be answering
questions like what is probation and its purpose
how should we be living in this probationary
period how do we reconcile the doctrine of
predestination with probation stay tuned
as we seek to answer these questions
and get a closer walk with our lord and
savior let us pray dear heavenly father
we thank you for this opportunity to learn
of you even on your holy sabbath day please
forgive us of our sins fill us with your spirit
prepare our hearts to receive your word and to
live it out in our lives we give you all the honor
the glory and the praise and we act in a special
way that you would rain down your spirit afresh on
your manservant elder randy skeet put your words
in his mouth oh god we thank you for hearing and
for answering this prayer in jesus name we pray
amen our first question two parts namely what is
probation and the second is what is its purpose
probation is a period of time that god
gives to mankind or to a higher beings
to carry out his will or to conduct themselves
in a certain way probation occurred before sin
probation occurred after sin what do i mean by
probation occurred before sin the bible says in ii
peter chapter 2 verse 4 so if god spared not the
angels that sin but cast them down to hell this
could only happen because the angels back then
were still on probation and elwrite makes that
clear as well in a conflict and coverage page 15
paragraph three like the angels the dwellers in
eden had been placed upon probation and so
the angelic hosts after they were made by god
were given a probationary period to let god see
whether or not they wanted to remain faithful to
him we do not know how long that period was but
god does not accept force or robotic service and
worship he wants worship by choice worship from
love and so created beings are given a period
of probation adam and eve were given a period
of probation some time in which to demonstrate
that they wanted to live god's way and so
probation is a time god gives as an act of
love and mercy in which we're supposed to conduct
ourselves in a certain way based upon his will for
us even in the legal system there's something
called prohibition instead of a prison term
the judge may give you probation with certain
conditions you feel you fulfill the conditions
you avoid imprisonment and so your probation
functions in the bible and in the larger society
but probation does not last forever and once
it is closed biblically it is never reopened
let me say that again biblically when probation
is closed it does not reopen and the purpose of
probation as i said is for a person of our people
it could be an individual or a people to meet
god's requirements to do what god would have them
to do god is eternal yes but his patience is not
amen i think we have to let that last
sentence sink in god is eternal patience
is not in prophets and kings page 276 paragraph
three ella white writes god grants to men
a period of probation but there is a point
beyond which divine patience is exhausted
and the judgments of god are sure to follow so
he gives us we see this with the antediluvians in
genesis 6 from verse 1 and it came to pass when
men began to multiply on the face of the earth
and daughters were born unto them that the sons of
god saw the daughters of men that they were fair
and they took them wives of all which they
chose and the lord said my spirit shall
not always strive with man meaning there are
limits to my passion for that he also is flesh
yet his day shall be 120 years and so god gave
him 120 years now peter comments on this in first
peter chapter 3 reading from verse 18 for christ
also hath once suffered for sin the just for the
unjust that he might bring us to god being put
to death in the flesh but quickened by the spirit
by which also he went and preached unto the
spirits in prison meaning the sinners in the days
of noah which sometime were disobedient verse 21st
peter 3 well while the the long suffering of god
waited in the days of noah while the ark was
preparing so peter is telling us that god
gave them a period of time his patience his long
suffering waited for a while as noah was building
the ark but we know when noah entered that ark and
god shut that door predation had closed for them
amen body of the israelites 490 years daniel
chapter 9 verse 24 it is critical to our
understanding of ourselves as a prophetic people
70 weeks are determined upon thy people upon thy
holy city and so we have that it's a it's a core
part of our teaching this 70 week prophecy which
is part of the 2300 days it was a probationary
period which ended in 1834 when the gospel went
then largely to the gentiles and so god gives
probation because people have to make individual
choices as to whether they'll serve god or not
adam and eve were given probation and they failed
by the way let me say something
frightening probation is not only
uh national or corporate it is also individual
patriots and prophets page 140 paragraph one
every day the probation of some is closing every
hour some are passing beyond the reach of mercy
when paul spoke to felix in acts chapter 24 verse
25 says and as he reasoned of righteousness and
temperance and judgment to come felix tremble
and said he said i'll call for you some more
convenience season and ella white writes in
patriots and prophets page four not patriots and
prophets acts of the apostles 4 27 paragraph 2 he
never received another call from god his probation
closed because he said no to a call of god sent
by paul and so they are individual probations
in first samuel 16 verse 14 the spirit of god left
saul he left him and an evil spirit troubled him
so probation closes individually probation also
closes on a larger scale because when christ
says he that is unjust let him be unjust
still that means the closing of prohibition
on a global scale he no longer is a priest he's
coming back as a conquering king and so we need
to understand probation is given globally
or nationally it is also given individually
and god never sends a text to tell
you when your probation will close
all you know you have today you have now
to do what's right in the sight of god
you